I almost wasn't going to talk about this
but Tucker Carlson's new Twitter show is
really really really bad and it is an
interesting media story to follow so
we're going to look at a couple minutes
of this Tucker released episode one
episode one of Tucker on Twitter it is
ten and a half minutes long it has been
viewed over 70 million times since
posted yesterday at 6 pm
um what I came away with is that when
you strip away the multi-million dollar
production of Fox News the expensive set
someone controlling the teleprompter for
Tucker now he controls it himself with a
sort of a mouse wheel of sorts a team of
producers and the graphics when you
strip it all away to its bare core for
lack of a better term
it turns out that Tucker is actually
pretty lame like Lamer than the average
YouTuber I have to say
let's take a look at episode one tell me
if you find this compelling
hey it's Tucker Carlson this morning it
looks like somebody blew up that kakovka
Dam in southern Ukraine the rushing wall
of water wiped out entire Villages
destroyed a critical hydropower plant
and as of tonight puts the largest
nuclear reactor in Europe in danger of
melting down so if this was intentional
it was not a military tactic it was an
act of terrorism the question is who did
it well let's see the kokovka dam was
effectively Russian it was built by the
Russian government it currently sits in
russian-controlled territory the Dam's
Reservoir supplies it's sort of like at
this point we're 37 seconds in it's
already obvious like okay if I watch
another couple minutes
he'll probably just blame Ukraine you
know it's like it's do you do we even
really need to watch this then we'll
skip ahead this is sort of like closer
to the middle just to give you a little
more of a sense of this Russians are
dying it's the best money we've ever
spent Graham says a smile spreads across
his thin quivering lips as he forms the
words he looks like a starving man
contemplating a breath sounds like he's
reading fan fiction now breakfast buffet
the aroma of death has aroused Lindsey
Graham thanks so much replies zolensky
he feels the same way right see there's
nothing dark here just two middle-aged
guys celebrating the killing of a
population they don't seem like the kind
of people who'd enjoy flooding Villages
or starting a famine in any case who
cares if they are it's really not your
business your job is to support Ukraine
watch Nikki Haley a republican candidate
for president explain this principle on
CNN a win for you all right so then he
plays a clip of Nikki Haley and then
we'll look at sort of the end and how he
wraps this whole thing
or will we now it's glitching badly let
me see if we can get back to the the
wrap up here here we go U.S government
has managed to classify more than a
billion so-called public documents so at
this point we can't possibly know what
our leaders are doing we're not allowed
to know
by definition that is not a democracy
yet it's fine with the media secrecy is
a powerful tool of control
stop asking how we got so rich here's
another story about racism go eat each
other
that's the program that's how most of us
now live here in the United States
manipulated by lies silenced by taboos
it is unhealthy and it's dehumanizing
and we're tired of it as of today we've
come to Twitter which we hope will be
the shortwave radio under the blankets
right we're told there are no
Gatekeepers here if that turns out to be
false we'll leave but in the meantime we
are grateful to be here we'll be back
with much more very soon
there you go folks and there is a little
outro with Tucker I guess fishing or
something like that yeah you know it's
it is very interesting when you see him
stripped of the accoutrements of
corporate media it's extraordinarily
mediocre the pace if you want to watch
the full 11 minutes I encourage you to
do it the pacing is very so so there's
too much time spent belaboring certain
points it just isn't very good and
that's what's really interesting when we
look you know the real media there's a
couple media stories here
what happens to Tucker's platform once
he's just posting videos to twitter
um one of the things you know I I am not
saying this to Pat myself on the back
but one of the things that is notable
about people who slowly build online
platforms like we've done on YouTube
Twitter Facebook podcast Etc is you
don't get a big audience you can bring
with you like Tucker got 70 million
views on this video because of things he
has done previously with multi-million
dollar production and that's great
that's a fantastic thing and who would
turn that down right that's a that's a
beautiful thing but one of the things
that's unclear is would he be able to
build it in the same way if he hadn't
been handed those things from these
major corporate media outlets and we
don't know the answer we'll never know
because he was able to bring this large
audience with him but to all the small
YouTubers and podcasters where we go you
know we I think back to the start of the
show we got a hundred downloads on a
podcast and then now we're approaching a
million downloads a month and 70 5
million views a month on video across
all of our different platforms when we
those numbers were built slowly over
time and there's a real question as to
what is this stripped down Tucker going
to be able to retain from that original
audience I'm as curious as anybody else
I'm also curious as far as a media story
is this a viable business of some kind
um and if so how is it going to be
monetized we will see we will see when
there's a non-fiction book I just don't
have the time to read having a summary
of the book is really valuable several
different platforms out there will
summarize books I've tried them all
short form is by far the most impressive
one and it goes Way Beyond what other
platforms do our sponsor short form not
only will Summarize the book covering
all of the key ideas short form also
provides analysis and commentary that
contextualizes the book comparing it to
what other books say about the same
topic and you can read or listen to the
entire thing in one sitting for instance
the book dark money by Jane Mayer about
how wealthy Republicans are covertly
influencing American politics short form
clearly and concisely sums up the book's
most important takeaways but it also
gives you a ton of other crucial
background about lobbying libertarianism
and that helps you really understand how
does the book fit into the broader topic
of conservative money in politics that's
why I love short form short form has
every genre politics business Tech
biographies and my audience can try
short form totally free and get 25 off a
subscription at Short form.com Pacman
the link is down below